oh my goodness how many people were in
there I told you I follow you on
Instagram thank you you're amazing I
work in a totally different industry I'm
not entrepreneurial but I just think
everything you're doing is so fantastic
you're very sweet I will have a good
session you too thank you
I'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
[Music]
here in Toronto in our new office should
be a good day I'm excited to see the
team meet some clients we're in Canada
now Dustin I'm excited about it
[Music]
I don't have different Visions for
different offices I have a universal
point of view of we would like to be the
best contemporary Communications company
in the world I want our culture to be
great here I want us to over the next
decade or two make it obvious to the
businesses that were the
disproportionate best option I want our
Global clients to know that this is a
smart place for them to expand their
footprint
hello how are you good to see you how
are you good good
how social media
good to see you brother well very well
goodbye can't wait we'll see you there
brother
oh my goodness how many people were in
there
thank you you're amazing I work in a
totally different industry I'm not
entrepreneurial but I just think
everything you're doing is so fantastic
you're very sweet I love those things I
will have a good session you too thank
you would love if you could share with
us a little bit more about your
philosophy on building a personal brand
maybe it links back to how we can build
a brand that matters for our businesses
too but what can each of us do to help
stay true in the lobby of the hotel now
three people stop me and then we win
elevator and I came out another woman
stopped me brand building is real the
reason I have so much conviction of what
I'm talking about is unlike every other
CEO of every other Agency on Earth I'm
actually the practitioner of The Craft
do you know how amazing it feels to have
1500 employees doing social media
marketing and I'm actually better at it
than them
this is important for everyone to hear
it's it I don't say that out of like not
a performance
not at all it's holding myself
accountable to be that for them
do you know how frustrating it is for
everyone here to have bosses that don't
understand their craft as well as them
it becomes tone deaf it becomes
political it becomes frustrating it
becomes it's deflating
like saying like selling something to
people under 20 and walking into a
meeting and saying hey we really need to
be on Tick Tock and having your boss's
boss say well I don't get it no
John you're 80. but we're selling this
stuff to 20 year olds
thank you
oh let me do a selfie
if you're stuck in on 37 and I'm not
where I thought you can't get out
all your energy is on your judgment on
yourself
place I go as kindness to myself
and say that's okay
who was I at 18 that made up this idea
at 37 like who are you when you decided
compassion to oneself the reason I'm so
lovely to everyone else is because I'm
lovely to myself
[Music]
the reason I don't judge all people is
because I don't judge myself like that
I'm also too thoughtful it's too come on
contextual right now we're just judging
each other
racism politics all this they're just
judging each other because we're judging
ourselves
so I would start with being nice to
yourself and then you start building
from there
[Music]
that's crazy
thank you my friend hope you have a
great night thank you so much
[Music]
that was a perfect way to end making
people smile is the best thing you can
ever do
[Music]
thank you